welcome back to the David pakman show I
Am David packman if there were a cloning
experiment that went terribly terribly
wrong
let's talk a little bit more today about
Heather McDonald and the right wing
obsession with race and racism and not
the the way that they project on the
left about being oh you're upset
everything's about race everything's
about race in the way that they want to
make white Christian nationalism the
order of the day for the country
and a lot of people push back when I say
that when I say that the Republican
party is the largest white supremacy
organization on the planet
I stand behind it
yesterday Charlie Kirk had a woman named
Heather McDonald on his show and I want
to get you a little acquainted with this
regular Fox News guest Heather McDonald
a woman who is a tireless defender of
police no matter what they do no matter
what news comes out no matter what video
is made public
tireless defender of police these are
some headlines Media Matters put
together from her various just a few by
the way not not all of them just a a
smattering of headlines of quotes from
her appearances with Tucker Carlson the
host of fox news's evening white
supremacy fireside chat
teaching diversity curriculum in schools
will destroy any possibility of further
civilizational advance
we should not be bringing more black
children into this country if Democrats
think America is racist
police are forced to arrest black men at
higher rates quote by the facts of the
crime and finally good law abiding
blacks aren't calling for the
abolishment
of police
leave it to aging white lady to tell you
what good law-abiding blacks are doing
well she was on with Charlie Kirk the
Twitchy zeppelin-headed freak over at
turning points USA another verging on
very dangerous character
and they were having a conversation
about policing you know after the
release of the beating of Tyree Nichols
it is now on the lips of every
conservative in the country either
making excuses for or outright denying
that there was a problem with it
and Charlie Kirk makes an assertion that
is is and has been and will continue to
be a legitimate white supremacist
talking point
many of you know that my my wife my
co-host and my partner in content
creation Brittany page was raised in a
virulent white supremacist household
we talk all the time about this
normalization of white supremacy and
white nationalism in the country things
that she grew up with only whispered
about in private are now on the public
agenda they are now on the docket for
Republicans to get Advanced as policy in
the United States and because of that it
has normalized Clips like you're getting
ready to see of Charlie Kirk watch this
the for years I've been told by
activists that blacks commit they don't
commit more crimes but the reason they
might and the statistics is because
there's more police in their
neighborhood it's the exact opposite of
a way to view it there's more police in
your neighborhoods because blacks commit
more crimes period
it's like you know we always hear about
well riots are caused by the police
showing up in riot gear and that causes
everybody to Riot no it's it's as you
say it's the exact opposite causality
the reason the police are there in ride
gear is you guys are rioting if you
don't want the police in Rye gear how's
about you stay home and or or protest
peacefully and don't start throwing
Molotov cocktails at police precincts
um yep he says smugly
one Charlie just a little bit of advice
maybe get a bigger shirt collar I know
you only have like a 14 and a half inch
neck but that collar is doing a lot of
work
to stay buttoned
neither here nor there though
the assertion that blacks commit more
there's more police in your neighborhood
because blacks commit more crime is just
virulently racist openly racist
and then the clip continues because then
they just they're breaking their own
arms patting themselves on the back
about all of the contributions that
Western culture has provided and
denigrating third world countries as
having done nothing for the world it's
all again part and parcel pattern and
practice standard operating procedure
for virulent Sinister white supremacists
watch this so you have heads of art
museums saying the Western Tradition 5
000 years of art is racist because there
weren't black sculptures in 5th Century
BC Athens well there were no blacks in
Houston yeah but they're willing to tell
people they're willing to tell young
people coming to museums for the first
time see this collection through the
lens of racial exclusion which is poison
classical music heads are also saying oh
the reason that there were no black
composers in in 15th century Flanders is
racism no the demographically Europe was
white until the 20th century so that is
heartbreaking but yes up to a point
you're right that the
the the elite white perpetrators of
racial preferences when it comes to
their own immediate lives do expect that
Merit will will Triumph on the other
hand
for their own institutions corporations
are uh mandating that managers get
promoted based their own hiring of
blacks and promotion of blacks and our
setting just Preposterous uh hiring
standards that can't possibly be met
given the academic skills Gap I mean the
it you it doesn't matter what objective
10 seconds
sorry we sorry Heather we're up against
a break but we're gonna have to be back
and just close the point show me
anything from the third world that is as
beautiful as Beethoven's Fifth you can't
some things are more beautiful than
others Heather thank you so much
others show me something from the third
world that's more beautiful than
Beethoven's Fifth you can't
he proclaims arrogantly
this is White Privilege run amok this is
two people glad handing one another
while trafficking in white supremacy
and this is mainstream republicanism
like it's never been before obviously
racism has been a creeper in Republican
politics for decades
we witnessed it with the with the
southern strategy and how how it gained
a foothold when Reagan announced his
campaign a Californian announced his run
for presidency in the 80s in Mississippi
and now it's taken a foothold
it's gross
every day we see more and more stories
about what tech companies and isps are
doing with your data Facebook just
settled a huge lawsuit alleging they
gave millions of users data to a company
helping the Trump campaign everyone
should be using a VPN every time they
connect to the internet no excuses a VPN
hides your IP address it can keep your
data private from these companies and
even from hackers that's why I reached
out to private internet access about
being our sponsor private internet
access is the only VPN that has proven
in court multiple times they don't log
your browsing history their no log
practices are also independently audited
by Deloitte no other VPN takes your
privacy this seriously lightning fast
for downloads streaming content only
available in other countries works as
well works with all major streaming
platforms with one account you can use
it on up to 10 devices and they have a
30-day money back guarantee and their 24
7 support is amazing go to Pia
vpn.com
Pacman to get 83 off that's two dollars
and three cents a month and you'll get
four months free the link is down below